none of you [__] on Twitter
were going to give me the ability to my
government wasn't going to do it so this
man out of the kindness of his heart
maybe it's for different reasons I don't
actually care I just want to see with my
eyes again what I want my kids to have
clean drinking water cuz nobody else
seems to give a like I think people
forget that aspect of it and they just
want to talk about Optics Optics Optics
Optics is for people who are privileged
when you don't have water to drink you
don't have the luxury to care about
Optics you just don't have water
there's controversy right now with Mr
Beast cuz he built 100 wells in Africa
and a lot of people feel some type of
way some positive some negative you know
what they say no good deed goes
unpunished so with that being said
because the story isn't that Mr Beast is
a no stradamus right it just based off
of historical data this was going to
happen he puts out a video where people
can't hear or they see and he's like hey
I'm Mr Beast I fixed it boom well that's
largely got him a lot of Praise there
been people going yeah [__] that guy
it's just uh you know performance
activism he's just trying to look like a
good guy this is part of the business
also I'm going to disregard that lots of
people's lives are made better cuz I'm
angry granted it would make sense if it
was at the system in the world but I'm
also going to direct it towards Jimmy Mr
Beast cuz [__] that guy and so when he
released his new video I built 100 wells
in Africa he kind of knew it was going
to come and in that video he goes to
Kenya Zimbabwe and other countries to
install Wells to give people drinking
water also notably speaking to the local
communities giving their schools new
equipment Mr be closing his video by
encouraging people to donate to the
water is life campaign at bees
philanthropy it's weird that a YouTuber
has to do all this stuff but someone's
got to do it and if no one else is we're
going to do it as you can tell it really
does change the lives of the communities
where we build them and so with that you
know as expected he got a lot of praise
for doing that people applauding him for
helping so many people using his
platform and money for good but as he
predicted he got some backlash with some
saying that he was exploiting vulnerable
communities for Content or some accusing
him of being a so-called white Savior
and arguing he's tackily packaging a
myth mostly to children that Africans
are helpless featureless subject of his
kindness that Africa can only be helped
by a white celebrity who's a Mass imense
wealth first how long do you think these
communities have been underserved in
regards to this water issue if someone
else was going to do it why haven't they
done it how long do these people have to
keep suffering before someone handles
their [__] while you guys were up here
virtually signaling on Twitter talking
about this how we should be done
somebody actually just went over there
and said I'mma do it and they did it no
but and guess you know you know who's
never complaining about this the ones
being helped sometime I'm I feel like a
lot of people feel like it needs to be
helped like Hollywood okay so the person
helping uh well it's African so cannot
be white right and that's white savior
so for it to be picture perfect it has
to be a black person that left the
community and came back and did a lot of
wealth by all those things that you're
staining in that thing the fact that
he's a celebrity the fact that uh he's
helping children uh the fact that he's a
he saves people can all exist without
having malicious intent I don't even
think these people think he has
malicious intent I think they're just
saying he's being harmful cuz basically
he's perpetuating stereotypes but I'm
like I don't give a [__] what
perpetuating stereotypes he's doing he
gives he if he gives me the ability to
see I'm happy cuz [__] none of you
[__] on Twitter were going to
give me the ability to my government
wasn't going to do it so this man out of
the kindness of his heart maybe for
different reasons I don't actually care
I just want to see with my eyes again
what I'm say I want my kids to have
clean drink get water cuz nobody else
seems to give a like I think people
forget that aspect of it and they just
want to talk about Optics Optics Optics
Optics is for people who are privileged
when you don't have water to drink you
don't have the luxury to care about
Optics you just don't have water like I
don't think people understand what it's
like to live in communities with no
clean water it affects your clothes it
affects the kind of things that go onto
your body inside your body like what do
you think the life expectancy is of
these kids if they don't get access to
this water what do you thing their
ability to go to school and learn is if
they constantly have diseases that
they're dealing with on the inside it's
not just water that goes to feed them
how do you give birth to new kids
without clean water to disinfect
everything how do you do anything from a
medicinal standpoint if you don't have
clean water in your community to do
anything it's normal that they take it
for granted we sh we [__] in clean
water that you know what I mean that
thing that you [__] in it's clean
water all over the world which they
could drink out of well of course online
everyone sounds off on things we
actually saw some activists agreeing
with parts of the criticism with for
example in a CNN report them pointing to
one aspiring Kenyan politician who
accused Mr bees of playing into a
stereotype you can never win cuz those
same people are the same people that
going to talk [__] about Bezos not doing
anything in with his money and if he
would have done something with his money
he would have been a white savior like
you can never win you can never win with
all this money you could do something
the guy with a lot of money does
something and he's a white savior so in
addition to that CNN talked to the
founder and CEO of the water INF
infastructure organization face Africa
who said I've been doing this for 15
years but we've been struggling to
continue the work because funding
awareness and advocacy all take work and
adding overnight this person comes along
who happens to be a white male figure
with a huge platform and all of a sudden
he gets all of the attention it's kind
of frustrating but it's also
understanding the nature of how the
world is and with that saying it was
good that Mr Beast installed these Wells
but also adding that doing it
sustainably is what matters by arguing
that it's one thing to install Wells and
another to actually have them working 5
years from now with their organization
face also going on to explain so much
more of the wider con I can understand
frustration like if you're trying to
make something happen off the ground
it's hard to get pennies you see this
dude coming with all this money and he's
fixing on such a larger scale you can
ever imagine it's like bro I got to ask
for Grants I got to fight for every
dollar and all of a sudden this dude
come out of nowhere I could understand
your ego being hurt by that but I you
got to put that [__] aside because it's
not about you it's about the people you
serve exactly your point your point was
to give people water not the fact that
you gave people water yep yep that's
what you wanted and here's the truth
about a lot of these NGS a lot of them
go and do this and they do this in ways
that are not sustainable they do this in
ways that require the NGO to constantly
be present in order to make sure that
the well keeps functioning so what ends
up happening is that the ngos ensures
itself that the government has to keep
funding it but if the government doesn't
then the people are stranded because the
NOS are the only ones who have actually
the ability to fix those Wells so I like
the idea of what Mr Beast did because he
created a long-term sustainability plan
and he also made sure that these things
could be maintain long term now if it
turns out that's not the case then I
have no issue with people taking
criticism but my understanding is that
is what he did okay and that's the case
with most of the stuff from what I've
seen I've never seen this man try to be
charitable in a way that isn't thinking
about the long-term effects of it right
he doesn't seem like he just wants to
hand people a bunch of crackheads a
bunch of money and be like well we
donated no let's see where that goes
most of the stuff he does it seems like
he follows throughs on it and he really
tries to make sure that they lasts for a
long time so for that reason alone I
have to show him some respect cuz I know
what it's like to live in those
communities I know what it's like to see
those communities I know what it's like
to walk through those places on a
regular basis and ain't pretty so I
could never in my heart of hearts fault
him for that cuz I know all those people
are just so happy he didn't just do that
he saw he built bridges in the video he
took time to really talk to the
communities and I just thought for me
obiously what active him activism looks
like when it's empty when it's empty
calories just for your own self
agulation and I've seen what it's like
when it's meant to be impactful and I
think as long as you're really thinking
through how you're going to help these
people I have no problem I don't care if
it's purple white blue pink rainbow
colored [__] TR I don't give a
[__] who it is they want to go and help
I encourage them to help just make sure
you're doing it properly that's all that
matters that's it all those so-called
companies or uh organizations that's
supposed to help people that go there
let's say oh we going to build schools
so they get a whole bunch of white girls
to go build schools over there and the
next day they undo the school or the
wall to have more people to come back to
pay money to and that's what I'm talking
about by malicious intent he doesn't
have that you understand what I'm saying
he just helps it and gets the [__] out
but no it's not the picture perfect
thing that you want your Hollywood
Picture Perfect winning thing that you
want your scenario that you want so
that's what I was talking about in
referring consequences that come from
not having access to water right because
Beyond causing serious illness it
prevents children from getting an
education because they need to help with
water retrieval this is something that
disproportionately impacts girls and
women as they're seen as the ones in
charge of managing water and cooking and
cleaning with faces website adding the
Lost number of potential school days in
education hinders the next generation of
African women from breaking out of the
cycle of unequal opportunity for gain
full employment with Safe Water nearby
women are free to pursue new economic
opportunities and improve their family's
lives also in the situation you have
others arguing that this whole
controversy highlights far more than
just the issues with water in African
countries some pointing to larger issues
with income inequality and
understandably while a number of places
have this issue a lot of the focus was
on Kenya as that's where a lot of Mr B's
video took place and actually with that
CNN pointed to a Kenyan activist who
suggested that Mr B's video brought
shame to the country they're saying
leaders get grants for cars but somehow
there's no money to drill more holes for
well so people going have drinking water
and actually to dive into that you had
Reuters doing a report back in 2018
noting that while Kenya's economy had
grown roughly 5% annually over the last
decade it has not been equally
distributed and has made the gap between
the rich and the poor wider and this is
a small minority of kenyons received the
wealth and it's not trickled down has
nothing to do with Mr
Beast that's not Mr Beast that's a whole
other problem with other other people's
doing those issues yeah it brought like
to some the people are are not helping
and everything and stuff despite the
growth that they're doing so let if you
tackle that and you say yo you point at
the government that should be helping
them and are not yeah there there goes
your problem yeah infrastructure in
Africa is like probably one of the
largest things holding the development
of the country back you still have so
many parts of Africa even like growing
economies that are like we're talking
about dirt roads places that are not
efficient the way they build the roads
around Mountain sides rather than going
through R tunel because they can't
afford to and then like inefficient
roads make blockades very common so it's
very easy for trade routes to be blocked
off Africa in general has a lot of
infrastructure issues what makes eent
worse is a lot of contractors are just
thieves straight up they get government
contracts they sit on the [__] work
they go very slowly to ensure that they
can accumulate the maximum amount of
wealth and because they have a monopoly
on this [__] they slow it down as much
as they can you know a lot of the things
holding back Africa and Africans in
general or greedy Elites that's just
what it is that's not a myth that's not
something I made up that's something
that's well documented is a fact go
ahead see where the money goes when it
goes to local governments you have too
many people in positions of power that
just lining their pockets so how am I
going to get mad at Mr Beast y'all
mother want to talk about stereotypes
stereotypes uh brother those stereotypes
are not lies that whole idea about a
leads being corrupt that's not lies I
got a little sense how many times are we
having government turnovers how many
times are we having Uprising a lot of
African nations because people want to
topple the government that's just making
deals with foreign governments to enrich
themselves at the expense of their own
people yep don't pretend like these
stereotypes are not there meanwhile it's
ordinary people who suffer so am I going
to get mad at Mr Beast who thinks about
them before for you or the elites or the
ones who can even afford to have a
Twitter account think about it most of
these people who are being served are
people who don't even have access to
something like a Twitter account dat you
think they got money for data to be on
Twitter I just want to be able to say
these parts I think his advocacy work is
great I've never met the man um but at
the end of the day anybody who gives
people the ability to see again the
blind video is probably the one that's
always going to hit home for me cuz I'm
just like living life in darkness is so
scary and the idea that this man gave
people the ability to see like that to
me is like incredibly touching if I was
struggling and my mom couldn't see and
that was like a daily struggle and I
just didn't know where to turn to and a
man helped her I I I would fight anybody
who tried to disrespect that man cuz he
gave my mom the ability to see me again
and for her to be able to walk to a
places and take care of herself like I I
don't think people understand the kind
of impact that kind of [__] has I think
it's sad that Mr Beast is the one who
has to do it sure but I will not let
anybody disrespect somebody who did
something so personally I'm very touched
by a lot of the stuff he does I think
it's beautiful and I think on YouTube
where I see so much [__] all the
time and Hey listen I probably pay pay a
play a part and cover it I think it's
just heartwarming to see that imagine
someone is is giving your mom the
ability to see MH and then you're like
oh yeah thank you for my mom's but um
you're really doing that for the wrong
reason and you're being a wh
savior listen I know you just give my
mom the ability to see but um you're a
white male
yay IM listen I know that you gave my
kids clean drinking water which will
help them succeed in flourishing school
and have proper development as human
beings but you're a white
male you are the patriarchy it's always
people that don't have nothing so I need
you to
apologize for saving my family for your
privilege and then I need you to undo
the
whale take it and
go and kill yourself it's crazy cuz it's
always the people that don't have
nothing to do with it and can't do
anything about it it's like okay so he
did that what are you going to do about
it [__] you [__] what
nothing okay so well we're going to
leave these people not drinking clean
water until the right person comes along
is that what we're going to do I guess
that makes no sense man carry on well
that's it for us let us know what you
think in the comments below